Netflix's post-apocalyptic thriller Bird Box
was its final hit of 2018, but now, the streamer
has been hit with serious backlash over some
footage featured in the flick.
Bird Box featured plenty of terrifying scenes,
but the sequence that has sparked the most
discussion wasn't fictional it was footage
from a real-life tragedy, and Netflix has
refused to remove it from the film.
It recently came to light that the film incorporated
actual footage from a 2013 fiery train crash
in the town of Lac-Mégantic in Quebec, Canada,
when an unattended 74-car freight train transporting
crude oil rolled downward and derailed.
Multiple tank cars exploded and caught fire,
resulting in 47 deaths.
Several other individuals were reported missing
at the time, and have since been presumed
dead.
Half of Lac-Mégantic's downtown area was
destroyed, and the majority of the downtown
buildings that didn't collapse or catch fire
in the incident were destroyed due to contamination.
The scene featuring footage of the real-life
disaster happens early on in Bird Box, and
while the filmmakers only used small bits
of the tragedy, Lac-Mégantic residents were
quick to notice that the clips were indeed
from the deadly accident.
Lac-Megantic Mayor Julie Morin told the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation that she and the
townspeople hoped that Netflix would remove
the footage.
She explained,
"We find that it's really a lack of respect,
to use these images as fiction and entertainment.
It's hard enough for our citizens to see these
images when they are used normally and respectfully
on the news.
Just imagine, to have them used as fiction,
as if they were invented."
Morin also noticed that the sci-fi series
Travelers — also on Netflix — had utilized
footage from the Lac-Mégantic disaster.
One of the producers of the show came forward
to apologize and explain that the images used
were sourced through the stock footage website
Pond5.
She added that there was, quote, "no intention
to dishonor the tragic events of 2013."
In a statement made to the Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation, she said that her team is working
to replace the footage.
It didn't take long for the people of Quebec
to stand up against Netflix for utilizing
the footage in Bird Box, either.
Quebec Culture Minister Nathalie Roy penned
a letter to Netflix's chief executive officer
Reed Hastings, slamming the company for its,
quote, "lack of compassion, empathy, and solidarity."
Netflix's public policy director Corie Wright
has since responded to the written complaint,
explaining that the video and images won't
be removed from Bird Box.
According to Bloomberg, Wright said in a letter,
"The use of stock footage is a widespread
and long-standing practice in the film and
television industry.
As a result, stock images are commonly used
within content on Netflix and on other services.
This widespread use prevents us from making
the changes you request on finished content.
[…] Going forward, we (and the broader industry)
can do better."
This is now the second wave of controversy
to crash over Bird Box, as the film stirred
up storms of contention when people began
participating in a dangerous social media
stunt known as "The Bird Box Challenge," in
which fans would blindfold themselves and
attempt to drive cars, walk through traffic,
or move down steps without getting hurt.
Hopefully Netflix can learn something from
this and, as the company said, do better moving
forward.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.